[Music]
episode 1 and two are good no doubt
about that I love the way they started
with addressing the 1959 Siberian
incident but then placing it in
Kazakhstan not really a big deal and the
Iron Dragon from the Philippines does
expand the monster list in a good way
but in episode 3 are they just going to
butcher our boy are they just going to
act like the first Titan Godzilla fought
in the modern timeline didn't even exist
this is outrageous I mean the
source material is right there shinamura
is the reason why s zawa exists in the
first place ishiro s zawa and his father
AG this video right here will highlight
the bad way the monst ver is heading on
right now in the third episode with the
third episode and coming from a die hat
fan of the franchise this is sad so they
canonized the bikini at all event
whereby the US military covered up them
trying to kill Godzilla with the use of
a Thermon nuclear bomb and classifying
it as a nuclear test the Castle Bravo
yeah that is true but only half true in
doing so they ignored or outright red
corn one of the fan favorite Titans of
the monsterverse that was showcased in
the comics Godzilla Awakening the Swarm
Tiant got the shinamura or the shamur
which means the swarm of death I mean at
least a few words before the explosion
would have done the trick something like
wait what is that or there's more than
one yeah you know something like that in
not doing so they also destroyed a very
valuable series of events that would
link one of the most beloved characters
ishiro Cawa with the Godzilla storyline
as we know there is a strong shinamura
serizawa connection meaning his father
AG serizawa was one of the first to ever
witness a Titan in real life after the
Hiroshima and Nagasaki bombings this led
to him joining the task force to hunt
down the shamura creature and then lorit
and Godzilla to the bikini atals to
destroy destroy them both with a Castle
Bravo nuke he would later pass on his
knowledge to his son ishiro sarawa who
would join leaw under the monar so
without the shinamura there is no ser
zawa and hence they would have to
redefine the character's backstory from
the ground up actually this is the
second wait a minute moment in the
series the first is the USS lorded
incident are they just going to ignore
the lorded incident and not dive into
the iron dragon's role in dragging a
gigantic ship Inland the moner could
have been the ideal replacement for the
shinamura if they wanted to actually Ron
the Swarm species and give it a new
identity it would have in fact been
great that the Iron Dragon that was seen
in episode 2 was actually a juvenile
that broke out of the ship and it was a
bigger one and adult that dragged the
ship to the middle of nowhere it would
explain in a way why a ship that size
near Hawaii thousands of miles away lost
to an encounter with a Titan was found
in one of the Filipino islands actually
that encounter invigorated ated Bill
randa's motivation to seek out these
creatures since he was the sole survivor
and no one really believed him or what
he saw but the USS L and plot as well
was just placed aside as a minor monster
encounter at this point I'm scared that
they will Ron the muto Prime as well
create another type of incident as to
why Godzilla lost his straight dorsal
plates and molded new Maple Leaf ones
there is a great risk of this happening
I feel like watching the rings of power
and hey I'm not safe this cuz I hate the
monsters or anything like that our
channel is actually built on the Titans
so I have a great deal of angs against
changing Canon low fans all over the
world of the franchise have one
particular question as well will they
ever show us any of the missing Titans
mentioned in king of the monsters seems
like quite a ways to tease the existence
of these monsters and yet not show us
any one of them well aside from Behemoth
Sila methusa and the queen Muto that
were already shown in kotm it's just a
waste of opportunity to be honest okay
we love the mediumsized monsters the
intricate design of the mole Titan the
what's it called the frost VAR and the
appearance on screen of the Iron Dragon
but what the fans have always wanted was
if they ever listen was an actual Titan
and not just a minor super species you
know sizewise of course we can classify
Titans as creatures with great power
over the surroundings as having a great
influence and not just Monsters of
massive size but that's just a bit
confusing to the lay man which is the
general audience who wants big monster
of course we will get that and gxc the
new Empire but this is just a loss of
opportunity to actually cement the
timeline of the most of us and not
actually confuse us with new stories
that contradict with the existing LW the
peran Titans origin story replaced by
The Hollow Earth okay it's actually
something good and that can be
understood as well because the perian
thing was only stated as a speculation
and not rooted in myths or facts but
deleting the existence of a beloved
Titan is just sad okay creativity and
originality M but like what happened
with The Witcher or the rings of power
stick to the source material or risk
losing actual fans the other casual
viewers would watch it nonetheless
anyway I do hope there would be a real
Global threat or an actual gigantic
Titan that Godzilla or Monarch must stop
later on in the series so those are the
disappointments and hard questions we
the monst of us fans have as of now and
thus this brings us to the end of the
video I'm not going to say like share
and subscribe cuz I'm annoy with this
right now anyway take care fam